ladies and gentlemen may I present his
Royal Highness
[Music]
Earl of the duchy of West Helia Prince
gerhardt messerschmidt Ramstein van hope
[Applause]
thank you
thank you all dear friends
oh ah who's Snow White NOW
7 45 and I'm still awake
Excuse Me Miss but uh His Highness has
noticed you who gerhardt really His
Highness is quite taken and invite you
to die next to him oh wow that's
flattering
are you sure that he met me
[Music]
tennis is attempting to wink at you oh
there you are
I need your help I've been asked to dine
with his majesty oh well if you're
looking to sneak out the window it
doesn't open I already tried it should I
say I'm still a virgin wait you're
actually considering this of course I'm
considering it you know I've always
reminded myself of Grace Kelly I'm not
going to be gorgeous forever who knows
how long this show will last and I have
no other skills whatsoever
I need to find someone who can take care
of me yeah I don't think gerhardt can
take care of you and I can get past
someone's looks since when I'm an
actress Liz it would be my greatest role
of all time you've already made up your
mind about this haven't you oh you're
right Liz I should go for it you're not
even listening are you poop monkey butt
no you're a good friend
[Music]
you are exquisite
would you like to dance sadly because my
body does not produce joint fluid I
cannot
I would enjoy watching you dance for me
[Music]
just
jump
jitterbug
Justin
keep trying it is now time for the kick
you're 25. yes can you believe it
finally old enough to rent a car ah
oh it feels good to laugh
happy birthday
[Music]
foreign
Jenna I know we have just met but I
think I love you
do you love me
oh
knowing I have the love of a beautiful
woman
has set me free
I think you just lost an eyebrow
to Freedom
[Music]
to us
thank you dear Jenna and goodbye
goodbye why goodbye
[Music]
drinks in he could not metabolize The
Grapes someone called her just for
chairman